how'd you get into your first MMA gym I  got kicked out of school  and I'm now just going to do what grade  I think I dropped out at 10th grade okay  I got kicked out in ninth grade  uh  so dude I was just angry man I was  [ __ ] angry  so I got into fighting because  it kind of scared me and you know I  thought I was like I [ __ ] you know  most people that want to hurt people  have low self-esteem correct you don't  really I mean unless you're like a  narcissistic psychopath most people that  enjoy violence and bringing pain to  people it's all low self-esteem yeah  they're hurting inside yeah so I always  stopped fighting scared me and I hated  it so I joined uh I went to a gym just  because like I didn't look like a [ __ ]  and I [ __ ] loved it first time I was  ever happy all the anger went away thank  God yeah yeah man [ __ ] dude